comenzamos reporteros gracias por
acompañarnos una nueva lucha se libra en
israel se trata de la revolución de los
pantalones cortos para ir a la escuela
una lucha de las jóvenes aparentemente
ligera pero que revela la gran división
entre secularismo y la religión dentro
de la sociedad israelí todo un tema de
pudor con la ropa femenina en el centro
del debate pues a los jóvenes si se les
permite entrar a la escuela con
pantalones cortos en esta emisión de
reporteros le traemos la historia de kay
una joven de 13 años expulsada por tres
días junto con sus amigas por llevar
pantalones cortos las adolescentes se
defienden y su manifestaciones para
vestirse como desean pero más allá de la
anécdota estas jóvenes israelíes
pretenden contrarrestar la creciente
influencia de la religión esta es la
historia
[Música]
ah
kai tiene 13 años detrás de su
apariencia un poco tímida a mediados de
mayo esta joven lanzó un movimiento que
generó debate en israel todo empezó tras
su regreso a la escuela después del
confinamiento
[Música]
y estaba vestido con este shorts en la
entrada de la escuela nos dijeron que
esperáramos la profesora nos condujo a
la secretaria y nos dejaron ahí durante
todo el día
y sus amigas se fueron excluidas tres
días debido a su vestimenta ellas
respondieron con la revolución de los
shorts que se volvió nacional
rápidamente hoy en la mañana esta joven
ha decidido poner a prueba nuevamente el
reglamento del colegio
compré un short un poco más largo veamos
lo que me dice
no temes ir a la escuela sabes después
de todo lo que ha pasado ya no tienen
derecho de excluirlas no te preocupes si
te dicen algo nos llaman
la madre de kai arquitecta apoyo a su
hija para ella renunciara el short es
capitular frente al crecimiento del
conservatismo en israel
yo también fui a clase con sortu corto
fue hace 30 años creía que habíamos
evolucionado desde entonces sin embargo
lo que observo es que estamos
retrocediendo enviamos fotos a un gran
diario israelí y a partir de ahí se
propagó en todos los diarios en todos
los canales
vamos a hacerlo a martillazos y mejor no
se trata del mejor los tres skin una de
las fotos tomadas por kai fue portada se
ven cinco adolescentes de espaldas en
shorts inmóviles en señal de protesta
la foto fue reenviada por otras por todo
el país en unos cuantos días en una
decena de colegios y liceos otras
jóvenes israelíes también fueron
excluidas debido a sus shorts
aunque ella
[Música]
varias manifestaciones fueron
organizadas por todas partes las jóvenes
denunciaron en especial una injusticia
fueron excluidas pero los hombres en sí
pueden entrar al colegio en el colegio
de cádiz en raanana fue desbordado por
la polémica la directora se negó a
hablar una consejera de educación de la
alcaldía aceptó dar explicaciones
está escrito en el reglamento los
alumnos están autorizados a venir en
shorts pero no muy cortos
la prenda debe llegar hasta el campo
tanto para los hombres como para las
mujeres no hay diferencias
la consejera no está molesta con kyle y
sus compañeras pero rechaza que esta
polémica se transforme en un combate
entre liberales y conservadores no
estamos en el caso de una profesora que
elegiría a los alumnos no vengan
vestidos así es un asunto de respeto en
la escuela hay que vestirse de una
manera respetuosa para con el colegio no
tiene nada que ver con el fútbol
[Música]
porque un simple short pude irritar a
tal punto del país porque detrás de ese
pedazo de tela se juega un
enfrentamiento entre dos israel que se
oponen desde la creación del estado hace
más de 70 años por un lado una población
occidentalizada con costumbres liberales
y por el otro una sociedad religiosa
conservadora en algunos muros de
jerusalén incluso se les recuerda a las
mujeres como deben vestirse para caminar
por el barrio
[Música]
etc
ah
hombres de negro cada vez más numerosos
en israel
[Música]
quién es
en este liceo de mujeres estamos a una
hora por carretera del colegio de skype
pero en otro universo
aquí los liceos enseñan el es mío el
pudor una norma religiosa más estricta
para las mujeres que para los hombres
es la base del judaísmo una mujer se
preserva una mujer no es lo que
comúnmente se llama dominio público
el pudor no es sólo de vestimenta el
pudor también está en la forma de ser
una manera de expresarse ya sea las
palabras tal vez groseras o una manera
de hablar o los gestos o la forma de
sentarse es un común
reglas restrictivas un universo sin
hombres echaron y sus amigas salieron de
francia para acercarse a la religión en
israel
[Aplausos]
esta es mi habitación cuando me levanto
a gwyneth y la
es un ritual que se hace todas las
mañanas para purificarse tomamos el
vocal hacemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y cuando
llegamos a 7 hacemos así
si lo primero
en el closet dejaron no hay shorts ni
pantalones solo puede vestir falda
por ejemplo esta se encogió un poco es
por mi culpa no sé lavar muy bien la
ropa pero normalmente no sobrepasa las
rodillas es el pudor no mostramos el
cuerpo respetamos los codos nos ponemos
camisetas hasta aquí no mostramos las
rodillas
la polémica surgida en raanana de judas
al internado
creo que no es una buena idea porque
equivale a provocar a los hombres
no es una prenda para ir a la escuela si
quieren ir a la playa sí perfecto pero
para ir a la escuela hay que tener un
poco de fútbol
[Música]
son reglas por nuestro vídeo no son
reglas que nos hacen ir en dirección
incorrecta son reglas que nos conducen
por el buen camino para ser buenas
mujeres creo
y creo que es bueno por mí misma me
siento incluso más respetada muestra una
faceta de mí no me miran por mi físico
sino por mi interior
el próximo a todos
en los corredores del liceo el rabino
clean vigila esas reglas de pudor
a tomás ahora
cuando el pueblo regresó a la tierra de
israel fue con el objetivo de crear de
nuevo un hogar judío en palestina crear
de nuevo qué quiere decir quiere decir
que hay una diferencia esencial que
vamos a vivir bajo las reglas del
judaísmo de lo contrario no habremos
hecho nada sería como si los judíos
estuviesen en ser seguido en nueva york'
el rabino clean que tiene razón israel
hoy en día no es un estado laico en la
calle en el gobierno los religiosos
tienen voz sobre casi todos los grandes
temas de la sociedad
en raanana en medio de esta batalla
entre laicos y religiosos kai ganó su
apuesta
[Música]
/ no me dijeron nada todas las niñas
estaban sorprendidas de que no me
dijeran nada estoy contenta de que no
hagan ningún comentario no miraron mis
orejas entre como si nada
las adolescentes observan la avalancha
de comentarios que generaron en unos
cuantos días
para muchas publicaciones en instagram
muchas historias vídeos y en facebook
miles de suscriptores casi medio millón
todo ese apoyo es muy importante en esta
historia porque sin apoyo nada habría
pasado
es el poder de las redes sociales un
contexto político más favorable en
israel el tema vuelve a ser de
actualidad cada año las alumnas
protestan para poder ir a la escuela en
short por ahora sin éxito
no es sólo una historia de shorts
aprendimos una lección para la vida
existir luchar por lo que pensamos hasta
que escuchen lo que queremos decir
para las tres adolescentes la lucha
termina aquí regresó a su vida anterior
la de la despreocupación en sus años de
bachillerato
a mí me gusta
pienso que la semana pasada
pero para brochas y muchas mujeres de
israel la batalla está lejos de terminar
al principio del verano eran miles en
tel-aviv los que manifestaban contra los
feminicidios
el debate sobre cómo deben vestirse
resurge cada año como si fuesen objetos
sobre los que hablan para saber si están
suficientemente bien educadas para
integrarse a la sociedad desde que son
muy jóvenes están confrontadas en
injusticias y no saldrán de ello eso las
persiguen hasta el ejército el trabajo
en la multitud hay miles de israelíes
denunciando el machismo de una sociedad
atascada entre rabinos y militares
[Música]
nuestra pancarta dice no es una
invitación no es una invitación para
violar no agredirnos a asesinarnos no
importa que llevemos puesto tenemos
derecho al respeto
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en las batallas se juega en la escuela
en la calle
los religiosos tratan de controlar el
espacio público pero en shorts ligeras
de ropa estas jóvenes resisten
hola
[Música]
y los religiosos siempre harán parte de
nuestro entorno pero nosotros los laicos
también tenemos nuestra propia idea
sobre la sociedad y no nos dejaremos
imponerse en el espacio público siempre
habrá desacuerdo en este tema
[Música]
una batalla para existir pero los laicos
no podrán a priori cambiar la naturaleza
de su estado esa es la paradoja de
israel creado para acoger al pueblo
judío y el estado césar ha de ser
religioso perdería entonces una de sus
principales razones de ser
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web más 24
punto com para ver esta emisión y las
anteriores siga con nuestra programación
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]